BOGOSIAN MOVES UP.
FIVE DEFENCEMEN.
BROKEN UP.
COLE CAUFIELD IN ALONE HERE
ALONG WITH SUZUKI.
AND OFF -- IN.
NICK SUZUKI, WON IT FOR THE
CANADIENS AND WE WILL HAVE A
GAME SIX.
>> Craig: THAT REACTION BY
GALCHENYUK IS A TURNOVER IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE ICE AT THE
OFFENSIVE BLUE LINE.
COLBY COVINGTON IN HIS SHORT
TIME AS A MEMBER OF THE MONTREAL
CANADIENS HAS MADE HIS BEST
MOMENTS IN OVERTIME.
THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF A --
AROUND THE SHOULDER, KOTKANIEMI
AND CAUFIELD.
NO FANS TO BE SHOCKED HERE, BUT
HUGS ALL AROUND FOR 22 AS THE
CANADIENS GIVE UP TWO IN THE
THEIR PERIOD, BUT HERE, 59
SECONDS IN THERE'S A NO-LOOK
PASS.
A BLIND ONE.
A LITTLE GIVE AND GO.
SUZUKI, CAUFIELD RIGHT BACK, AND
YOU CAN SEE THE REACTION.
>> JUST ONE OF THOSE PLAYS THAT
YOU CAN'T MAKE AT THE OFFENSIVE
LINE, AND THIS ONE SHORT PASSES,
QUICK REACTION, AND RIGHT OFF
BACK OF THE NET TO MAKE THIS A
SERIES.
>>> AND THE SHOOTER MAKES THE
PLAY.
NICK SUZUKI HAS HIS SECOND OF
THE SERIES, AND HE'LL TAKE IT
BACK TO MONTREAL WHERE THERE
WILL BE FANS CHEERING ON
SATURDAY NIGHT.
>> Craig: I THOUGHT IT WAS
INTERESTING, TOO.
HE JUST DIDN'T WANT TO TAKE IT
END TO END.
THAT PASS MAKES IT A DIFFICULT
ADJUSTMENT FOR CAMPBELL.
YOU CAN SEE HE WAS STUCK IN THE
MIDDLE.
HE'S THINKING, OKAY, THE BOOK IS
ON CAUFIELD.
HE LIKES TO SHOOT THE PUCK.
INSTEAD ALL OF A SUDDEN THAT ONE
PASS GETS IT BACK.
EXPECTING A SHOT.
DIDN'T GET IT.
AND SUZUKI SENDS MONTREAL HOME
DOWN 3-2, BUT